hemos definido ya la noción de una
proyección sobre un sub espacio pero no
he demostrado que definitivamente sea
una transformación lineal tampoco he
demostrado que si conoces una base de un
sub espacio como encontrar una
proyección sobre él así que veamos si
podemos hacer algún progreso en ello así
que digamos que tengo aquí ve un sub
espacio es un sub espacio vamos a
escribirlo bien un sub espacio sube
espacio de nuestro ya famoso y conocido
r n nuestro espacio de n dimensiones y
vamos a suponer que conozco aquí una
base de nuestro sub espacio ve digamos
que esta base tiene a los elementos b1
b2 así sucesivamente hasta beca o que
esto es una base de nuestro sub espacio
ve y esto me está diciendo entonces que
la dimensión de nuestro sub espacio es k
ok entonces qué significa esto esto
inmediatamente me está diciendo que si
yo tomo cualquier vector digamos un
vector a en el sub espacio ve este
vector yo lo puedo expresar como
una combinación lineal de elementos de
la base es decir puede encontrar un
ayuno que al multiplicarlo por ver 1 más
1 2 por b 2 más así sucesivamente hasta
llegar por beca esta combinación lineal
es exactamente igual a nuestro vector y
eso es lo que me está diciendo que esta
base ahora bien vamos a expresar lo de
otra forma si yo tengo una matriz a
digamos y voy a construirla como la
matriz que tiene como columnas a
nuestros vectores b y entonces tengo
aquí el vector de uno como columna de
dos como columna y así sucesivamente
hasta el vector bk y estos son son
columnas
y claro que son columnas cerrarlo igual
con morado esto por supuesto es una
matriz bueno como cada cada vector vive
en rn porque nos tomamos elementos del
sub espacio b que vive en rn entonces
tengo n coordenadas aquí verdad entonces
son n columnas perdón n filas el n
renglones pero tengo acá columnas ahora
sí entonces esto es de n por k muy bien
entonces si nosotros tomamos un vector a
digamos un vector a que se encuentre en
el en el sub espacio b sabemos cómo
podemos expresar lo como esta
combinación lineal sabemos que existe un
vector que tal que al multiplicarlo por
la matriz a nos da exactamente
el vector que teníamos y esto es para
algunos para algún vector
que se encuentre en rk y ese es tener ek
porque tenemos cada constante es verdad
y aquí pues a final de cuentas tiene
cada columna la matriz entonces
necesitamos que este vector se encuentre
en r acá entonces esto que nos está
diciendo que sí que va a existir un
vector que tiene coordenadas de 12 así
sucesivamente hasta llegar que al
multiplicarlos lo que me da es
exactamente de 1 x b 1 más de 2 x de 2
más todos estos llega por beca muy bien
eso es lo que nos está diciendo pero
ahora sí vamos a saltar esencialmente a
lo que queremos hacer en este vídeo
porque lo que queremos demostrar es que
es una transformación lineal entonces
que las proyecciones sobre su espacio
son transformaciones lineales entonces
voy a considerar cualquier elemento de
rn vamos a partir de cualquier elemento
de rn nosotros vimos que la definición
de la proyección
que la definición de la proyección sobre
un sub espacio ve de x pues
necesariamente se encuentra en nuestro
psuv espacio b pero si se encuentra en
nuestro psuv espacio b podemos aplicar
exactamente lo mismo que hicimos con
este vector a quiere decir que vamos que
vamos a poder encontrar un vector y tal
que la proyección sobre nuestro psuv
espacio ve de este vector x es igual a
la matriz a por el vector y para algún
pues para alguno
alguna que se encuentre algún vector
y que se encuentre en er está muy bien y
esto aún no sabemos quién es y si se dan
cuenta nosotros quisiéramos encontrar
una expresión para esta proyección pero
no nos m no nos han dicho cómo encontrar
este vector y hay que repasar muy bien
tenemos una base de nuestro psuv espacio
y entonces cualquier vector en el sub
espacio se puede expresar como
combinación lineal de estos construimos
esta matriz a que la matriz cuyas
columnas son los vectores de la base
entonces cualquier vector en ese sub
espacio lo puede expresar como a por
otro vector que aún no sabemos cuál es
y eso en particular se puede aplicar
para la proyección sobre el sub espacio
de nuestro vector x entonces vamos a
avanzar un poquito más en esto porque x
x sabemos que lo podemos descomponer
como la suma de dos vectores donde de
hecho lo habíamos escrito como ve más w
y b no era otra cosa más que la
proyección sobre el sub espacio de x y
había que sumarle otro vector que
habíamos dicho w que no es otra cosa más
que la proyección pero sobre el sub
espacio ortogonal de este vector déjenme
queda claro que es este vector pero voy
a escribirlo como lo teníamos con w para
simplificar un poco la anotación y vamos
a escribir aquí que
un único elemento
el elemento del complemento ortogonal
debe ok entonces si esto es cierto
entonces podemos escribir bueno pasar
este vector restando y tenemos que x
menos la proyección sobre el b qué
espacio vectorial b de x es igual es
igual a w es igual a w entonces tenemos
que este vector de aquí como es igual a
w w
un elemento del complemento ortogonal
entonces éste se encuentra en el
complemento ortogonal de nuestro espacio
espacio b
ok entonces vamos a escribir algunas
cositas más porque quién es el espacio b
pues si nos damos cuenta él
el espacio columna de nuestra matriz a
es el espacio b y eso es cierto porque
el espacio columna es el espacio
generado por los vectores columna de
esta matriz pero otra vez los vectores
columnas que construimos justamente son
los elementos del
de del espacio vectorial ve entonces
generan a nuestro sub espacio y de esta
forma podríamos ver que quien sería el
complemento ortogonal de nuestro espacio
vectorial pues es esencialmente el
complemento ortogonal del espacio
columna y que ya habíamos visto en
algunos vídeos atrás quizás como 3 o 4
que esto es el espacio nulo de nuestra
matriz a transpuesta o lo que es lo
mismo el espacio nulo izquierdo de la
matriz ok entonces
esto me está diciendo que x menos la
proyección sobre el espacio b de x se
encuentra en el complemento ortogonal
por el complemento ortogonal es el
espacio nulo de la matriz transpuesta
entonces esto será x menos la proyección
sobre el espacio b de x se encuentra en
el complemento ortogonal de b que por
cierto es el espacio nulo de la matriz a
transpuesta
muy bien esto me está diciendo una
ecuación me está implicando que si yo
multiplico la matriz a transpuesta por
este vector por este vector que es x
menos la proyección sobre el espacio b
de x esto por estar en el espacio nulo
de esta matriz me debe dar igual al
vector cero
muy bien y esto lo podemos distribuir
esto lo podemos distribuir por ser
lineal y tenemos que la matriz a
transpuesta por equis menos la matriz a
transpuesta por la proyección de vez de
x sobre b nada más que hay que
considerar algo porque la proyección
dijimos cómo se encuentran en nuestro
espacio vectorial b lo podemos expresar
como a por un vector ya que es el que
queremos encontrar entonces esto de aquí
esto de aquí no es otra cosa más que a
por algún vector ya que aún nos falta
determinar quién es entonces aquí abajo
lo podemos escribir como a transpuesta
por la proyección qué es
y esto debe ser nuevamente igual a 0
simplemente lo que hicimos fue sustituir
esta expresión y multiplicar todo por la
matriz a transpuesta y de esta forma
pues tenemos que la matriz a transpuesta
a transpuesta por el vector x por el
vector x debe ser igual pasando esto del
lado derecho a a transpuesta por a por y
ok simplemente pasando esto del lado
derecho ahora bien si si nosotros
encontráramos quién es el vector e
inmediatamente tenemos dado que la
proyección sobre el espacio vectorial de
x está bien definido porque porque ya
aquí sí ya es conocido entonces es
fácilmente calculable o quizás no es tan
fácil en términos de hacer operaciones
por al menos ya no tenemos que
desarrollar más teoría ahora bien la
pregunta es podríamos despejar de esta
ecuación y para hacer eso necesitaríamos
que la matriz a transpuesta x a sea
invertirle
se ha invertido y cómo vamos a resolver
este detalle
bueno pues hace unos vídeos ya atrás
dijimos el siguiente resultado si ya es
una matriz cuyas columnas cuyas columnas
columnas
o cuyos vectores que forman las columnas
son linealmente independientes entonces
entonces la matriz a transpuesta por a
es invertible siempre es siempre
invertible
invertible siempre muy bien este
resultado lo hice hace ya algunos vídeos
y lo dice explícitamente pensando en
este momento entonces como la matriz
estuvo formada por los vectores de la
base y para que sean base necesitan
forzosamente ser linealmente
independientes entonces esta matriz si
es invertible esta matriz si es
invertible y por lo tanto vamos a tener
que que podemos multiplicar por la
inversa del lado izquierdo de ambas
expresiones y así poder despejar y eso
se da de la siguiente forma tenemos que
si multiplicamos por a transpuesta a a
la menos 1 que existe por lo que ya
acabamos de mencionar y luego
multiplicamos por lo que está aquí a
transpuesta x esto será lo mismo que si
multiplicamos a transpuesta por a a la
menos 1
transpuesta
porque sin embargo esta matriz por esta
otra matriz como son inversas al
multiplicarse me da simplemente la
matriz identidad y esto me está
concluyendo que la identidad porque eso
solo es que debe ser igual a la
siguiente matriz a transpuesta a la
siguiente expresión más bien a
transpuesta x a a la menos 1 x
transpuesta x muy bien ahora podemos
definir la proyección de la siguiente
forma porque realmente como teníamos
definido de la proyección era así
teníamos que la proyección la proyección
sobre un sub espacio b
me fui del lado de un vector x era igual
a la matriz a porque donde no sabíamos
quién era y esencialmente solo sabíamos
que ya estaba en r acá
pero ahora ya podemos definir de la
siguiente forma o la proyección como la
proyección es a porque simplemente me
quedan definido de la siguiente de cómo
voy a escribirlo ahorita la proyección
sobre el sub espacio b del vector x pues
va a ser igual a nuestra matriz a esta
de aquí por ya que es esta expresión x a
transpuesta a a la menos 1 x transpuesta
x y ahora sí esta es una función que
depende de x de forma explícita y esto
ya es una transformación lineal porque
porque todo esto pues será alguna matriz
no sabemos cuál exactamente dependerá de
de la elección que tomemos de la base
pero es una matriz es alguna matriz y
por lo tanto es también define una
transformación
lineal
ok esto ya es una transformación lineal
y acabamos de demostrar por qué es así
es una transformación lineal porque es
una matriz por él y por ese vector
entonces qué fue lo que hicimos esto
realmente es bastante difícil de
calcular si uno lo quiere hacer con
papel y lápiz porque primero uno tiene
que encontrar la base del psuv espacio
vez sobre el cual queremos proyectar
construimos la matriz y entonces tenemos
que calcular varias cosas tenemos que
calcular la matriz a transpuesta
multiplicar la para calcular su inversa
y después multiplicar la por a entonces
este cálculo es bastante complicado si
uno lo quiere hacer con papel y la
piscina embargo es muy útil en
programación gráfica en tres dimensiones
por ejemplo supongamos que tenemos por
aquí algún algún sólido en tres
dimensiones digamos como como alguna
especie de cubo
tenemos un cubo y nos preguntamos si
tenemos a un observador de este lado a
través de una pantalla que tenemos aquí
una pantalla y el observador ve a través
de esta pantalla cómo se reflejaría o
cómo se vería este cuerpo sólido en este
espacio que esencialmente es un sub
espacio verdad entonces lo único que
necesitamos es considerar la base de la
pantalla y todos estos puntos que forman
este sólido y los proyectando sobre este
este sub espacio que es una computadora
lo puede hacer muy fácilmente y de forma
muy rápida con esta forma de expresar la
proyección así que si conoces una base
de esta pantalla de tu pantalla a través
de la cual quieres ver el cuerpo puedes
proyectarlo fácilmente así que este
resultado en realidad es súper útil